take a guy like warren buffett when you
think about investments you think about
a warren buffett right you
take a ray value you got to put him in
there right ray dalio what he's done
himself
you know buffett is talking about silver
hey he put his money in silver right now
i think he's sitting on 200 billion
dollars of cash is what he's sitting on
imagine if that 200 billion dollars
would have been in
portion you know crypto 800 you're
talking about 1.6 trillion dollars
is what uh uh berkshire hathaway would
have had
it would have been the largest company
in the world even bigger than amazon and
the other
if they just would have put their cash
in there but buffett
is not bought in ray dalio's critical
about it because he thinks regulation is
going to get to it
do you think what is happening is the
old-timers who have had their set of
philosophies
that's worked for them for decades
they are so set in stone with the way
they see what's worked for them that
they're not
willing to break from it to say hey
maybe we have to
take a look at what's going on with
crypto do you think
the next phase a lot of these old-school
heavy-duty people that we've respected
for decades are going to be
exposed not even exposed like they don't
know what they're doing obviously they
know what they're doing
but maybe their method of investment is
outdated for 2021. and these are people
you and i admire these are people that
we have a lot of respect for
what do you think about that yeah so i
think it's important to call it right
out of the gate anyone who says that
warren buffett is an idiot
or ray dalio or you know name your kind
of favorite uh
kind of historic uh return investor uh
yeah they're just being intellectually
dishonest so they had an epic run
they're absolutely some of the best
investors in the world
now with that said they made most of
their money
or the decisions they made that made
most of their money in a different world
right it wasn't a digital technology
driven world for the most part as we
know it today
and so when you look at you know a
warren buffett for example
uh he hasn't outperformed the s p for
the last decade
now again that doesn't take anything
away from his track record he's one of
the best investors in the world
but the world has either changed or he's
the rational person in an irrational
world
so you can take your pick as to why the
you know this is played out this way but
he hasn't beat the s p in the last
decade and so if you had taken his
approach
you've underperformed now there's plenty
of people who say well look at uh
somebody on the extreme
other end masayoshi sun from softbank
right who
i don't think anyone thinks that
masayoshi and warren buffett sit down
and they're like we're gonna pick the
same stocks we're gonna pick the same
investment strategy right
but sure masayoshi everyone thought he
was crazy and also looks like softbank's
vision fund's going to do pretty dang
well
and so i think when you start to really
unpack some of this you've got to look
at
okay what is the environment that we're
in this technology-enabled kind of
digital world what are the investments
and what i think that we're starting to
unpack here is
there's a lot of hero worship that
happens in the financial markets right
it's because you did something
10 years ago or 20 years ago of course
you're going to be smart here
sometimes that is true but i think
that's a very dangerous precedent to
kind of fall under and so what i like to
do is just simply look at and say
okay what are you trying to accomplish
for a young guy like me
it's asymmetry right and so that
asymmetry ends up being really important
because you can risk less capital and
there's a higher payoff more risk but
higher payoff
and so if that's what you're looking for
it's actually the exact opposite thing
of what warren buffett is trying to
accomplish
right warren buffett understands he's
got 200 billion dollars in cash he's got
this big machine
he wants to protect his wealth he wants
to continue to compound it if you can
compound
you know uh hundreds of billions of
dollars at eight ten percent a year
you're going to do just fine
bitcoin has compounded a 200 compound
annual growth rate for a decade
so simply just holding bitcoin right
would have drastically outperformed
warren buffett
now that doesn't mean that either one of
those people are right or wrong it's
just they're optimizing for something
different
and so what i think will end up
happening is the older generation the
the folks who are kind of
um at the ends of their career they're
not gonna come around right they just
a lot of them will even say that i'm not
a technology investor i don't understand
this stuff it violates a lot of my world
view
i just i'm a value person or whatever
their strategy is
what i do think is likely to happen
though is a lot of the younger people in
their organizations
as they rise up in kind of power
influence and positions
they'll start to diversify into a lot of
this so
there will be a day where berkshire
hathaway buys bitcoin it's probably not
going to be warren buffett pulling the
trigger on that decision
it'll probably be somebody else listen
foresight you know great uh
great uh prediction of what could
potentially happen but it's it's got to
be pretty tough to be done because
even the other day for example when i'm
asking about the biggest enemy that
crypto may have bitcoin may have right
um janet yellen not a fan you know that
she's not a fan
powell not a fan uh ray dalio said
there's probably going to be regulation
coming to it i mean i can give you a
list of names
plethora of names politically that are
not for what can happen to
crypto and bitcoin and all of that what
is the worst thing
you know because some people say if you
really understand bitcoin
you will know they can never regulate
bitcoin right you've hear you've heard
that saying before millions of times by
uh pro
crypto folks but what is the worst thing
a yelling a power a biden
the political people can do to the
crypto world
well i think they've already probably
done it and hasn't stopped it right and
so i'll give you
two scenarios uh one is an international
scenario where we have some data points
and then once what's happening in the
united states
uh so internationally we've seen people
ban it right we've seen pakistan
we've seen nigeria uh china we've seen
multiple countries go and ban it and
when they ban it guess what happens
adoption goes through the roof right so
actually by banning it you're almost
running a marketing campaign
and especially in those countries where
people already have a distrust for their
government
the second the government says don't do
something they ask why does the
government not want me to do that
right and they actually go and they
adopt it yeah um and so i think that
banning it
is a great example of what not to do for
a government
if a government wants to quote unquote
attack bitcoin or be adversarial to
bitcoin
the better thing for them to do would
probably be overly regulatory right or
like have an overreach in the regulatory
realm and so if you look at bitcoin
bitcoin is the most regulated currency
in the united states
and here's what i mean by that if you
and i go to dinner
and you buy dinner with dollars you
simply pay sales tax on that transaction
if i buy uh dinner with bitcoin i not
only have to pay the sales tax
i didn't have to pay capital gains short
or long term on the purchase
because it's treated as property for me
now cashing out to
uh to pay for this thing and so from a
regulatory standpoint there's actually a
financial incentive for me
not to use bitcoin in the united states
right that that is a
obstacle that even though it's in place
this year bitcoins on chain transaction
volume meaning people actually using it
not for trading on exchanges but
actually using it for whatever purpose
will be over five trillion dollars of
on-chain transaction volume that's more
transaction volume this year and last
year than venmo
apple pay or paypal so people who say no
one's using it like wait a second this
jamie dimon said chase is 7 trillion so
wait a minute
did you just say it's 5 trillion just
for bitcoin
in the last 12 months if you take uh the
current
on-chain transaction volume you just
annualize it right it'll be over
seven trillion dollars of transaction
volume on the actual bitcoin blockchain
this year in 2020 seven or five seven or
five seven
seven got it yes and so when you start
to unpack some of this
you really start to understand that okay
even though there is this big obstacle
around taxation
right people are still using it the
second thing is everyone forgets
you don't actually ever regulate an
asset right it's not like you're gonna
put the dollar in jail or you're gonna
go and get the dollar bill and scream at
it and say give me your tax money
so same thing with bitcoin right the
asset itself isn't what gets regulated
it's the organizations and the people
who use it transact support and have
related services to it
and so in the united states a crypto
company is subject to all
of the same rules and regulations as any
financial company if you need to have a
money transmitter license in the regular
finance world you need to have it in
crypto if you need a broker dealer
license kyc
aml all that stuff but in certain areas
let's say in the state of new york
if you're a crypto company you have to
get an additional license that the other
financial companies don't have to get
something called a bit license
so it's actually harder for you to
conduct a crypto business in the state
of new york than it is for you to
conduct our traditional
financial institution and so in some
crazy way
bitcoin and the crypto ecosystem is more
regulated than the traditional financial
system
and that kind of blows people's minds
because they're like what do you mean
how is this possible whatever
well if you tax it more than other
currencies and then you make the
companies get additional
licenses that other financial companies
don't need to get then what you're doing
is you're actually putting up these
obstacles
even though all of that's occurred you
have in the liquid market a two plus
trillion dollar market cap
bitcoin's a trillion dollar of that and
then on top of that you've got multiple
multi-billion dollar companies within
the united states have been built in
this industry
and so no matter what regulation you put
in the way even if in other countries
you ban it or in the united states you
simply try to overregulate it
it doesn't matter people have spoken
this is superior technology it's a
better system
they want it and they're going to use it
and just like they did to uber and
airbnb where they try to use regulation
and kind of all of this political
overreach it doesn't matter if people
want it they're going to get it and
that's the new paradigm in the
technology
world is the technology is superior from
an adoption standpoint
to any sort of regulation you can put in
a way you can disincentivize it all you
want
if it is better and it has product
market fit it will be adopted
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye